[Musik]
sprechen wir mit derjenigen die das neue
vorgehen in schulen in
nordrhein-westfalen verantwortet mit der
ministerin für schule und bildung in nrw
yvonne bauer
hut ab vor gebe ich grüße sie frau gebe
aber kein präsenzunterricht bis ende
januar warum
ja weil die situation des leider
erforderlich macht und der beschluss der
kanzlerin zusammen mit den 16
regierungschefin und regierungschefs
nicht allzu viel spielraum ermöglicht
wir wissen um das mutierte virus wir
haben eine sehr deutliche datenbasis in
bezug auf die zahlen und wir kennen die
auswirkungen der silvester- und
weihnachtsfeste noch nicht und das hat
uns hier nordrhein westfalen wie viele
andere bundesländer auch dazu bewogen
hier auf nummer sicher zu gehen und den
distanz unterricht jetzt einzurichten
ein schulleiter einer grundschule aus
essen erzählt dass er erst in den
nächsten wochen eine ladung ipads
bekommt dann müssten aber erst die
lehrer darauf geschult werden eltern aus
leverkusen und kamen bei dortmund
erzählen mir dass sich lehrer nicht
melden und dann vielleicht ab und zu mal
aufgaben kommen alle erzählen aber das
gleiche die schulen seien komplett
überlastet und weitgehend unvorbereitet
wie kann das sein zehn monate nach
beginn der pandemie
ja ich würde jetzt nicht sagen
weitgehend unvorbereitet wir haben hier
in nordrhein westfalens weise fort
ausstattungs programme aufgelegt 1 für
die lehrerinnen und lehrer dass wir alle
lehrerinnen und lehrer mit digitalen
endgeräten versorgung 1 für die
schülerinnen und schüler aus familien
mit besonderen bedarf
diese programme laufen ich weiß dass
schon viele digitale endgeräte an den
schulen angekommen sind es fehlen
tatsächlich geben da immer noch wir
haben genauso fehlen ja offenbar noch
viele haben wir eben in dem beitrag ja
auch gesehen und es gibt offenbar immer
noch kaum online unterricht also
tatsächliche video calls mitschülern
sondern zumeist werden einfach aufgaben
auf lernplattformen gestellt und die
schüler werden dann mit ihren eltern im
zweifel eben alleine gelassen wie kann
das sein
wir haben über die vergangenen wochen
und monate unserer lehrerin
lehrer in vielen videokonferenzen
geschult wir haben eine handreichung
erarbeitet zum distanz unterricht in
verknüpfung mit dem präsenzunterricht
wir haben viele hinweise und tipps
unseren lehrerinnen und lehrern gegeben
um auf diese situation vorzubereiten
plus eben die beiden sofort
ausstattungsprogramm und ich hoffe dass
das jetzt alles zum tragen kommt liegt
das also an den lehrern habe ich sie
richtig verstanden das heißt die lehrer
sind vorbereitet und machen im endeffekt
nicht das was am besten für die schüler
wäre
nein die lehre sind vorbereitet
natürlich schulen wir parallel noch
weiter es ist eine besondere situation
ja und natürlich hat in diesem maße
distanz unterricht über wochen so noch
nicht stattgefunden
aber wir haben von unserer seite alles
daran gesetzt dass dieser distanz
unterricht jetzt gut anlaufen kann ich
weiß dass die lehrerinnen und lehrer um
ihre verantwortung wissen und distanz
unterricht muss nicht immer digital
sondern kann auch analog funktionieren
gerade bei den jüngeren schülerinnen und
schülern der frau gebe ich höre ihnen ja
sehr genau zu sagen dass es jetzt
anlaufen kann also nur fürs protokoll
das ist jetzt zehn monate danach und
jetzt schauen wir mal auf den beschluss
von gestern
wie soll dieses anlaufen denn jetzt
funktionieren bei grundschülern die
sollen ja jetzt auch offenbar vor dem
rechner beschult werden wie geht das bei
6 78 jährigen die dann im zweifel
alleine vor ihren rechnern sitzen in ein
grundschüler müssen nicht vor ihren
rechner gesetzt werden grundschüler
können werden die ausstattung im vorfeld
schon vorhanden gewesen ist natürlich
auch digital auf distanz unterrichtet
werden aber in der vergangenheit hat
sich schon auch gezeigt dass die
grundschulen ihre schülerinnen und
schülern mit arbeitspaketen für die
woche hin versorgen mit aufgaben
versorgen und dann entsprechend auch
diese arbeitspakete wieder in empfang
nehmen bewerten und dann die
schülerinnen und schüler motivieren dann
an den nächsten aufgaben auch weiter zur
arbeit das verstehe ich jetzt nicht ganz
sind sie jetzt der meinung dass also
eine beschulung mit eben auch video
calls auch in grundschulen und daneben
auch in weiterführenden schulen sinnvoll
ist weil dort natürlich ein viel
direkter kontakt stattfindet oder sagen
sie nein diese lern pakete die eltern
teilweise dann in großen teilen ja den
schülern vorbei bringen die reichen
völlig aus für die beschulung von
grundschülern
nein wo immer das möglich ist und die
gerätschaften zur verfügung stehen
sollen natürlich dann auch kinder auch
in den grundschulen schon digital mit
lernplattformen dann auch entsprechend
wenn man auch immer gedacht er war doch
wie ist es für die schüler sowie können
sie einen 6 78 jährigen vor einen laptop
setzen und der soll dann alleine
sozusagen mehrere stunden lang sich
konzentrieren jetzt widersprechen sie
sich nicht widersprechen mir nicht es
gibt sowohl die eine form als auch die
andere form und sie können einem kind
das schreiben nicht per video beibringen
und natürlich sind damit aufgaben
verbunden und deswegen sind an der
stelle auch aufgaben blätter wichtig und
die werden dann durch die schulen
erstellt und den kindern zur verfügung
gestellt aber immer dann zum beispiel
auch bei viertklässlern wo bereits schon
digitale erfahrungen gemacht worden sind
sollen diese natürlich auch genutzt
werden nach zwei wichtige punkte sollten
wir noch schauen einerseits auf die
abschlussklassen auch die sollen jetzt
erst mal nicht in die schulen hätten sie
da nicht sagen können gerade bei den
abschlussklassen in abiturs klassen da
testen wir einfach im zweifel jeden tag
eben diese schüler oder jeden zweiten
tag und machen dort präsenzunterricht
wir haben sehr intensiv über mehrere
stunden hier mit lehrerverbänden
schulleitung vereinigung gesprochen wie
wir das gestalten mit den
abschlussklassen weil wir ja auch die
möglichkeit bekommen haben dass diese in
den unterricht kommen dürfen
und natürlich können sie das dann wenn
das gewünscht ist aber wir haben gerade
bei diesen älteren jahrgängen die
erfahrung gemacht bzw wurde uns das
bestätigt dass hier einen online lernen
sehr gut in der vergangenheit
funktioniert hat aber wir haben auch die
ausnahme gemacht dass für schülerinnen
und schüler wo das nicht funktioniert es
trotzdem unter hygienemaßnahmen erlaubt
sein muss dass diese dann auch in den
schüler in den schulen dann noch vor ort
unterstützt werden können mit tests oder
mit hygiene testballon mit corona test
was heißt sollen diese dann getestet
nein mit den unter unter nein unter den
chor ohne schutzmaßnahmen das heißt dann
eben mit maske und mit abstand damit wir
hier die größte sicherheit dann auch in
den schulen weiter gewährleisten können
alle ihre beschlüsse von gestern ich
habe das sehr genau gelesen soll ich
zitiere das zu nehmen
ist bis ende januar gelten haben sie
gestern ja auch gesagt natürlich wissen
wir alle ja nicht wie die krone zahlen
sich entwickeln werden haben keine
glaskugeln aber es ist ja schon jetzt
absehbar dass die zahlen dann
möglicherweise nicht signifikant
runtergehen wie lange können aus ihrer
sicht kinder zuhause beschult werden
oder schlägt irgendwann dann doch das
bildungsrecht von kindern und
jugendlichen jede sorge um infektionen
ich darf ihnen sagen dass ich nicht
erfreut gewesen bin über den beschluss
den die kanzlerin zusammen mit der
ministerpräsidentin und
ministerpräsidenten getroffen hat und
blieb auch nicht viel spielraum in bezug
auf die auslegung des beschlusses und
von daher hoffe ich dass wir
schnellstmöglich jetzt wieder
zurückkehren können in den
präsenzunterricht und zunächst heißt ja
nicht nur eine verlängerung sondern kann
ja auch bedeuten wenn die zahlen sich
derart positiv entwickeln dass wir auch
früher wieder starten mein bestreben ist
es dass die kinder so schnell wie
möglich wieder in den präsenzunterricht
bekommen wollen der bildungsauftrag
wichtig ist aber auch die sozialen
kontakte die nicht verkümmern dürfen und
das können wir nicht leisten über den
distanz unterricht aber wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe wenn die
ministerpräsidenten und die
bundesregierung entscheiden es geht noch
weiter mit dem lockdown hieße dass auch
weiter lockdown für schüler in nordrhein
westfalen nein das hieße es nicht weil
wir ganz klar auch gesagt haben hier
bildung muss vorangestellt werden vor
allen weiteren maßnahmen wir haben uns
jetzt darauf noch einmal verständlich
dass auch schule seinen beitrag leisten
muss was die kontakt reduzierung
anbelangt aber allen ist klar dass wir
hier jetzt das maximum herausgeholt
haben dass es danach mit distanz
unterricht so nicht weitergehen darf das
ist eine klare aussage yvonne bauer die
ministerin für schule und bildung in
nordrhein-westfalen ich danke ihnen sehr
dass sie sich hier bei uns bei phoenix
gestellt haben sehr gerne